[Music]
mike you know we haven't checked in on
in a while um
the kid from bad santa all grown up okay
no the catcher from the sand lot look
this is who
buddy lemvak if he ate charles
jewish greg the hammer valentine
this is um greg the negotiator valentine
this is
this is a we we watch a lot of lily sing
stuff right
because we hate ourselves and we just
are just terrible terrible terrible
people
and um this was uh something that i
thought we should play
the thing that you know lily doesn't get
a lot of credit for mike
being a good interviewer well it's
because she's not a good interviewer
royce that's probably why
the main reason that's uh that's
probably right apparently
she had um this thing fortune
themes who's fortune feedster how would
i know that royce
how why would i know that why are you
mad at me relax
i'm mad at you for even asking me that
question you're like well who
is who is that all right fortune
feamster is an
emily fortune femtures an american
writer comedian and actress
to made her television to be on nbc's
last comic standing
between 2015 and 2017 she starred as
colette on the mindy project i think she
was on the show last comic standing
with bouts of occasional sitting i gotta
sit down once in a while
okay she was actually on the spin on
show last comic apnea
let's play it let's see the interview
skills these are just
mike two funny broads just going back
and forth the news
can be pretty hard to read these days
yeah no i know it's important
you know what i would do if i was her
right there right off the bat the news
could be pretty hard to read
are you setting up a bit what are you
doing i came here to promote my pride
are you setting up a bit
you're sitting up a bit right now you're
setting up a bit hey
she's setting up a bit all right let's
hear what frankie uh
what ralph you may have to say it's not
ralphie may
man i'm only with lily's thing yo
i prefer rafi's fake black accent to
lilies
to read these days yeah now i know it's
important to keep up with current events
even if it can be depressing so it's
time for another edition
of sad news
this is you could run the show on fiverr
absolutely of course you can run the
show on fiverr yeah
this show looks like an early ustream
podcast yes
but like back like when you'd have like
one on there that was taking it really
seriously and you'd be like wait why are
you on you stream
lily's thing should be on blog talk
radio
so we're gonna read some real headlines
i repeat these are absolutely really
real wait so she's doing the bit that
leno stole from letterman
yeah they did that that's called
headlines
and as always brace yourself because
these are really
very this is ridiculous still stealing
the headlines from me which is uh
clearly mine because i stole it from
steve allen yeah so i don't want it
let us hide in her closet just for
taking angry notes
i'll call dick episode i don't have his
phone number he no longer works here
he's just calling dick why are you
calling i'm not there anymore
i told you i've been dead for years jay
i've been dead since 1997.
stop calling me
sad news the north pole's christmas and
ice was canceled
oh he's still alive i'm sorry dick amber
salt is still alive
hey we apologize to dick ebersol's
family i was thinking i was actually
thinking of brandon tartikoff
there you go our apologies to the
ebersol family
and the tardikov families yes bad news
the north pole's christmas and ice was
cancelled
due to lack of ice
not only does she think this was funny
she started laughing in
in the middle of it christmas and ice
was canceled
due to lack of ice
sad news a nude man was arrested after
being found in a chicken coop
his excuse for being there was that he
did
way too much mess all right listen andy
richter
i know that's you you could you could
pretend it's not you andy richter
but i know and also you know what this
bit needs
in the year 2000
this [ __ ] all she does is rip off every
other talk show and pretend like she's
an original
like this is this is back and forth all
right
what are you going to what are you going
to fark.com and reading wacky headlines
to be fair you're not giving him a
chance i am i'd
like to hear what dr steve creme brulee
has to say come on man that's not fair
you pick dummy
[Laughter]
sad news oh in this segment you could
tell was recorded without an audience
there
because sometimes there's an audience or
something it's not this is can laughter
i can already tell you can laughter
watch
and it's why you're right though not
only did they steal in the year 2000 but
the entire format of it oh yeah of
course when they're transitioning back
and forth and everything
r kelly's lawyer is complaining that the
singer can only visit with
one of his girlfriends at a time
children
sad news german piglets were given a
chance to defend their rights
in court to stop themselves from being
neutered
and one of them went to last common
standing and sitting here right now
can they talk
they're good at riffing i don't know why
does this why does this
kid from bad santa also dress like
they're unveiling a new apple device
it's everything about this
she looks like she works at a genius bar
she looks like she's about to shoot tony
soprano with that jacket on
they do that she looks like tj miller
she looks like
she's like bruce valanche but she's
dressed like eugene pontecorvo and i
don't like it it's bugging me
she looks like bruce hidden valley ranch
in my brain it's adorable
sad news a man too intoxicated to work
his steak and shake shift
robbed the restaurant instead
why are these funny well it's funny
because poverty's hilarious racism no
no it's not even that this is this is
they're going to
this she sounds like she's going to prep
burger well
it is prep burger and just reading the
headlines and laughing at that that's
all they're doing they're doing the news
of the weird remember news of the week
yeah but but normally you would like
we there's some there's sometimes we get
stories that we're like wow that's a
great but then we read the story you go
oh it's because of this i mean
but she's just she's basically she's
basically your mom on facebook who just
reads the titles of something and shares
it
it's she's also what i like about it is
like all right
people like maury povich people like
jerry springer steve wilkos these are
all guys that have a rich
dedicated history of exploiting poor
people
and their hilarious drug field mistakes
for profit
but they always do it under this guise
of like you know this
sort of dr phil sort of i care like at
the end of the show we're gonna give you
some sam's club gift cards
you know and a month of family therapy
because we care
whereas now it's like these people just
read stories of like
so this guy who worked at a steak and
shake right
obviously uh unstable drunk
and uh probably had mental problems and
uh substance abuse issues so he decided
to rob the place
he was supposed to go to work at because
he obviously has
uh really terrible uh mental health
issues and probably was raised in a home
where that's normal
yeah what i said was we have dr pepsi a
dr pepper is that fine there's no mr
pibb thank you
just add the laughs later
relatable y'all how is it relatable
you're a multi-millionaire who's bragged
on being on being on a selective app and
you live in a mansion
how is this relatable you've never had a
real job in your life
you've been groomed to do this it's
there is a
there is this weird you're right how is
this relatable to who does this
relatable to
she just says things that she's like
women
say in comment sections of posts girl
girl it's not relatable like yeah to be
honest with you omg this is so me
i don't but that's the thing like
relatable is like you watch the joker
movie and you go i've had times where i
felt like i was
you know i've had time for i wanted to
kill robert de niro world was a terrible
place at all you'll find like little
moments in a movie where you go i relate
to that little moment there
but like this is we're meme culture now
now it's like oh my god
robbing a [ __ ] sticking a gun in
somebody's face and tear while they're
terrified on their nine dollar an hour
shift
so i could take their money run laid up
all you're like that doesn't sound
relatable at all
and by the way i've done some shady [ __ ]
back in the day to survive
never in my life have i ever been like
all right so check it out we'll go in
there
i'll stick a gun in that bitch's face
and we'll get the money
like it's never come to that yeah this
is kind of not relatable yeah this isn't
an m
m song
sad news a florida man drove us for rock
lay off me i'm starving sorry into the
water
when asked for a comment by police he
said
jesus told me to
that's the joke what is this thing again
this woman
this is the death this is the death of
western culture
this is a death of comedy this is what
happens when you allow women to run the
show remember when you'd have like
that's what this is i know i've done
this bit before i don't care i'm doing
it but remember like
you know johnny carson would have like
ava gardner pop in and then
don rickles would come in and make fun
of a little everybody would smoke
cigarettes just smoking
smokiness cigarettes having a little fun
there was no forced bits